well now we're getting somewhere all we
have to do is run those table creation
queries by calling exact sequel at the
end of our on create function but wait
there's another function in our SQLite
open helper on upgrade you might think
why should I care about those I'm not
upgrading anything yet
to make our development lives easier
we're going to implement the most
standard kind of on upgrade there is you
see on upgrade only fires if you change
the version of your database remember we
pass that version into the SQLite open
helper base constructor ages ago since
we are going to be using our databases
of cash for web data and not for user
generated content will drop the tables
this is helpful if we want to change the
database in the future if we were using
user data we'd do something like use
alter table to add new columns so now we
have a database